All
the
books here.
They're all,
they're all at the coop.
Does anybody else missing syllabus then
this will be the set up was missing a
syllabus.
Anybody else?
All the,
all the readings at the top are in the
coursebook.
That's abnormal in the coffee and the
books that are listed below,
they're all separate books.
Okay.
Well let's just go over there.
Are you ready?
Okay,
let's go there.
Oh,
alright.
I should welcome my extension school
students too.
We'll be looking at this morning.
Okay.
If you turn to the back of the syllabus
where it says two calendar of events,
the titles that are listed on the right
hand side are all chapters from the
coursebook that sap?
No moon coffee.
Okay.
And then if you look at reading list and
due dates,
so is it agile readings?
Those are all books that are responsive
to this one,
which is for weeks one to three or books
that are available at the coop.
Okay.
And the address for noman coffee is 13
olds for Massachusetts Avenue.
All right.
And as I said,
there's a mixture of
analytical psychology texts that's
basically young in psychology.
Some philosophy,
some literature and some more
neuropsychology and not basically covers
the domain of the course.
So I'll start the introduction here.
Okay.
This is a course about
the causes of social conflict.
Um,
I'm not interested in social conflict
from the perspective of a political
scientist or a sociologist.
I'm interested in intergroup conflict,
but not at the level of group analysis.
I'm interested in what role social
identity or group identity plays in
individual psychology and why it is that
individuals are motivated to participate
in acts of conflict.
Um,
are you using for an example here,
the Holocaust,
I was thinking last week reading part of
the preface to the book that you're
going to read about the Holocaust museum
in Washington.
There was a lot of heads up,
obviously this is a museum to hope to
the Jews primarily who were killed by
the Nazis in World War Two.
And there's a number of museums like
this throughout the world and their
central model is never forget,
and this has always been confusing to
me.
It's notion of never forgetting because
I don't think you can remember something
that you don't understand.
And I don't think we understand why the
Holocaust happened in World War II.
I think.
I think you might regard the Holocaust
as none learned lesson and I don't think
that you can process information you
don't comprehend,
so we'll just say never forget things.
The question is what is it that you're
supposed to remember and use it?
The fact that 6 million people were
killed,
does it?
Is it the fact of that particular event
or are you supposed to be giving some
consideration to holocaust like events
that have occurred through history.
There are people who think that what
happened in World War II was a
relatively unique event of something
unparalleled in history.
This is not a position that I adopt.
I think actually it's a very common sort
of event.
It was perhaps
it was the event of that sort that has
proved most shocking to the European
conscience,
so to speak,
but it's hardly strikes me as unique and
people often talk about the Holocaust in
terms of the relationship between the
Jews and the Germans are between the
Jews and the Nazis.
The Jews obviously playing the part of
victims and the Nazis often for always
playing the part of the perpetrators.
And of course this has absolutely
comprehensible from the historical point
of view,
but it also strikes me that if what we
remember is that the Nazis killed the
Jews that were already on the road to
making a mistake that similar to the
mistake that was made that led to the
Holocaust to begin with,
which is to identify characteristics
that lead to patterns of action of that
sort as characteristics of groups
identifiable groups.
And it seems to me,
I mean I'm not trying to equate the role
of the Jews and the Nazis and producing
the Holocaust that would obviously be
observed,
but what I'm trying to say is that the
last one,
it seems to me to be,
especially when you consider that the
propensity for home costs like events is
deeply rooted in human nature.
The lesson to draw from the events of
World War II with the,
that's what human beings are like,
not what the Nazis were like because
these sorts of events happen all the
time.
I mean,
it's obviously the case that there are
well in the 20th century alone,
English and bent at the concentration
camp in South Africa,
Germans,
her fact that Chinese used it to great
advantage,
Solzhenitsyn estimated,
I'll show this on the next slide.
66 million people in the Soviet Union
were killed as a consequence of internal
repression,
many of whom went through camp like
procedures on their road to their
demise.
See ethnic cleansing occurring in places
like Rwanda and even once again in
Europe and the Balkans,
whatever it was that we were supposed to
learn from the events of the Second
World War hasn't been learned nor being
remembered because you can't remember
what you don't understand.
That's what this course is about.
I'm,
I've been working for since 1985 I guess
on trying to figure out what it is
about.
People
remember how to read that.
Maybe you know this,
maybe don't.
She's a famous political scientists.
She was a student of Martin heidegger.
She wrote a book called the banality of
evil and one of her points was that
these people,
she was talking about the Nazis in
particular,
people who perpetrate events like this.
If you meet them,
if you talk to them,
if you have encounter with them,
the thing that's often striking about
them is not their striking abnormality
or their evidence to eval,
but the fact that they're very much like
other people that you might've met,
which was suppose putting be surprises.
So surprising when you think about how
thoroughly,
for example,
the Nazi movement dominated the German
punches and sort of likewise with
communism in the Soviet Union.
I mean those ideological movements
characterize people.
They didn't characterize some strange
sort of misfits whose consciousness was
characterized by something in
comprehensible that led them to perform
the kind of actions that we are
theoretically supposed to remember.
My perspective on all of the assistants,
the fact that people are capable of
perpetrating atrocities like those that
characterized the Holocaust.
It says something about what people are
like,
what everybody's like,
because it's strikes me that that kind
of tendency is something that's deeply
rooted in human nature and then to say
that,
but what was it about the Nazis or what
was it about the Soviet communists that
led them to participate in this sort of
behavior is completely decided to point
in a sense.
All that does is you're looking for some
sort of group characteristic.
It's devoid and you don't have any
personal relationship with that group.
The problem is instantly made abstract
and as far as I'm concerned,
if it's abstract,
well then once again,
nothing is remembered and what I want to
do is to try to,
I want to outline the reasons why.
Something like the whole,
the costs incurred,
what it is about us that make us so
concerned with protecting our group
identities,
what those identities mean,
what role they play in the regulation of
emotion.
That's the critical thing right there
for me,
idiot ologies are,
are,
are the expression in a sense,
the verbal expression of the internal
structures that regulate our emotions.
When you mess around with someone's
ideologies.
Therefore as a consequence,
you're messing around with the
inhibitory structure that regulates the
interplay between their emotions.
So we're going to study in part in this
course of what emotions are and how
they're rooted in neuropsychology and
neurophysiology and how they manifest
themselves and behavior and how they
might be controlled and how that might
tie into something as abstract as social
identity.
Usually there's no question that a link
made between the concept of sociological
processes,
so to speak,
and inter psychic processes or
neuropsychological structures,
but it's obviously,
if you think about it for a moment that
whatever your identity is plays some
role in regulating your emotional nature
and your of your physiology because your
thoughts are embodied.
They're part of your mind,
you're part of your brain.
Do you want to get right down to it?
People have belief systems and they'll
do anything to protect and I find that
peculiar is what is it that's so
important about belief system that would
lead people to do things.
Normal people as far as I'm concerned,
to commit acts that under normal
circumstances would would be conceived
of as incomprehensible even by those
people.
So I also hope to make,
as I said,
I want to make the lessons here
personal.
I'm not interested in discussing the
issue from the abstract perspective
because I don't think that an issue,
an issue of this magnitude deserves to
be discussed.
Data at an abstract level.
It's not an abstract problem.
It's something,
there's something peculiar about us that
we have to learn to control because as
far as I'm concerned,
we're to the technologically powerful to
remain at the whims of the
uncomprehending aspects of our nature
piece,
predictability and the delusion of self
representation.
What does that mean?
Well,
if you can predict something as a
general rule,
it's hard to determine why it is
that you think you understand something
when you think you do.
If you think about it for a moment,
it gets complicated because you're
surrounded by things that at some level
of analysis,
you cease to understand.
It doesn't matter what what phenomenon
it is,
and even even the most mundane objects
become mysterious.
If you look into them foreign,
take something as simple as a chairs
made out of wood.
That's all.
There's nothing remarkable about that.
But if you start to look into the
structure that wouldn't count.
Organism Mitre produced it.
All of the chemical reactions that go
about bringing that about and the
developmental history that led to the,
to the emergence of plants and trees.
But it can see that even in something
mundane or and banded all sorts of
mysteries.
But for the large part we traded show
something.
We understand well that's in part
because we're only concerned with it
with regards to its function.
And if it serves the function of being
able to be sat upon,
then we don't pay any more attention to
it.
So we think that if we can predict the
behavior or something that we understand
it.
So in peace when we observe ourselves
acting peacefully,
we presume that we'd got ourselves under
control,
that we actually do understand about
each other because we can predict the
behavior of others.
Then we can predict their own behavior.
Now deludes us into thinking best
therefore our models of ourselves or
actual actually accurate representations
of what we're like,
wow,
the problem is in wartime we don't act
like we do in times of peace,
but then of course during war time when
people are committing violent or
socially aggressive acts,
they don't really have all that much
time to sit around and self reflect.
So it's not a time to be to be building
models about who it is that you are and
why it is that you're that way you're
too busy doing whatever it is that you
happen to be involved in to protect your
territory or to take someone else's
territory or two to expand your
ecological dominion or whatever it is.
Peaceful Times.
We look at ourselves,
can we see ourselves being peacefully
they bleed and nice name,
who make the precept position that as a
consequence,
that's what we're like and that we also
understand herself.
This is a big mistake because if you put
someone under extreme circumstances then
there will be things about them that
will be revealed to them that can only
be revealed under extreme circumstances
and it's extreme circumstances that were
concerned about in the course of this
course.
I want to find out,
I think that one of the things that
ideology does a group identity for that
matters,
regulating our emotions and if you're a
member of a community that has a
successful ideology and so the social
structure is basically stable and
successful,
then your emotions are regulated so well
that you don't even know that they're
there.
Just to say that you're protected by
something that you don't understand from
something that you don't comprehend.
And when I want to do is open the gates
a little bit and let you see what's
underneath your comfortable social
identities and what it is that you're
protected from by the weight of your
history.
Well,
this is the central question I guess.
Then like first of all,
I think social aggression is a primary
Cuban characteristics.
If you even have a cursory knowledge of
history,
it's obviously the case work or plays in
the man's role.
And it seems to be the case that this is
also true down the find a genetic
lottery.
I mean for a long time it was thought,
for example,
the chimpanzees live peaceably and this
appears to be the case as long as you
studied chimpanzee's within their own
family or kin unit or I suppose roughly
speaking tribe,
he had a piece of lead to each other
even in their dominance,
dominance dispute.
So usually settled more or less
peacefully good.
All discovered not so long ago that
chimpanzees conduct wars and clan wars
by,
by all occurrences when a chimp group is
faced with an interloper from another
group or with another group that they're
capable of engaging in the same sort of
behavior,
have much,
much more fundamental level in the sense
that we are and also seems to be the
case as we'll see a little bit later in
this discussion that similar things are
true.
Even animals is as simple,
so to speak is wrapped,
uh,
looks like the capacity for.
So it's strange.
It's strange because it's obvious that
people have a tremendous capacity for
social affiliation.
I mean,
we made groups in the West.
People are usually considered as rugged
individual,
less so to speak,
but it's all,
it's the case.
Even in the most individualistic of
societies that were constantly in
contact with other people.
Almost all our environment,
there's other people,
we're all members of literally often
dozens of groups,
families and in groups devoted towards
certain tasks and and so on and so
forth.
We're very,
very,
very social thrive in a social
community.
But it looks like the flip side of that
is the fact that we're so capable of
making social groups also makes us very
capable of organized aggression against
other social groups.
So it's,
it's the strange phenomena that it's our
very capacity for social organization
that also gives us this terrible
capacity for social aggression.
So that's another thing that I want to
take a look at it of course,
like I really want to get at the core of
this too.
I,
like I said ago,
I'm not interested in messing around
with a question on an abstract level.
I want to end the course with concrete
answers about why it is that people are
capable of doing the sorts of things
that characterize not to behavior say
during the Holocaust.
I want to make that so crystal clear
that you can map out the argument from
precept position a tick to conclusion d
so that it's socially and personally
approved,
clickable and so that you also get a
glimpse perhaps of what might be
necessary from the perspective of
personal and interpersonal conduct to
alleviate the likelihood that you'll get
trapped into doing something like that.
It's one of the things you pointed out
cause he was very concerned with events.
The second reward and social aggression
in general,
he said you have to understand is that
these great evils tend to take place one
small step at a time.
Do people get tracked into them over a
long period of time?
You make a small bad error but it
doesn't look so big at the time at least
to another type of error.
That snot so baby as well.
And that leads to a third era and he
spoke so big.
But if you've put together 40 of those
areas or 50 of those errors and all of a
sudden you see that someone's traveling
down a road to a place where they might
not want it to have gone in the
beginning,
have they been conscious of it?
So one of the things about never
forgetting is to understand
is to engage in primary prevention,
so to speak,
which is to understand how the sweetness
in the second half of,
of course has to do with that issue,
particularly personal relationship to
group identity and group fostered
action.
So the first part of the course
basically deals with why it is that
we're susceptible to social aggression
as a consequence of our biological
makeup.
What it is about us that makes us like
that.
And the second part of the course is
about how certain patterns of personal
calm down heighten the possibility is
socially aggressive acts will take place
and about how it is that you might avoid
engaging in all sorts of that.
That's
an overhead
detail.
Some of the things I've already
discovered.
So good home here.
I'm going to tell you a story from the
Soviet Union.
It's soldier knit some total.
He introduces it with the home from the
Russian poet Mayakovsky
with cohesion,
construction,
grit and repression.
Bring the neck of this gang run riot.
That's nice.
Pole social knits and wondering who was
the game.
That's the question.
As I said,
he has to make 66 million people died.
The Soviet Union between 1917 to 1959
Solzhenitsyn also estimated that is
substantially larger number of parish in
Communist China.
No one really knows the staffs on that.
Now this is a debatable statistic as
Social Nixon points out in this book,
this is from the Gulag archipelago.
As he said,
as soon as the official statistics are
released to revise his estimates.
This includes,
for example,
several millions million hasn't pushed
into the Tundra and forced relocation in
your early twenties 6 million
Ukrainians,
we six months.
You have even the famines in the 1930s
pretty good a story.
So this is the situation.
So what did,
did she tell you a little bit about his
life story?
You go like archipelago is a three
volume.
The second volume of which you will read
is his story about the blue light.
Good light.
It was a system of forced labor camps
set up in the Soviet Union soon after
late and die.
In fact,
yes,
some of them were set up before he died
and upon which the Soviet economy duty
ran for much of,
it's for much of what constituted its
life.
Soldier Solzhenitsyn's started,
he has traveled through the ghoulag
originally as a Russian is frontline
soldier.
So neat story and Sam's got thrown into
a German prisoner of war camp and when
he was repatriated to the Soviet Union
stabling through Beta in a concentration
camp.
And the reason was as he did with all
the return Russian prisoners of war who
are treated by the way terribly and the
German prisoners of war camps because
stellman refused to sign the Geneva
Convention on the treatment of
prisoners.
So not only were they in prisoners of
war camps,
which was miserable enough that they
were starved to the degree that the
other allied prisoners used to give them
food.
They didn't have much food themselves,
so he was a front line soldier.
Then he got thrown in a German prisoner
of war camp and then when he finally
returned to Russia,
Stellan through and the concentration
camp,
and the reason for that was that the
Russians who were in German prisoners of
war camp had been contaminated by their
exposure to western ideas and that was
his rationale.
So anyways,
then he spent a decade and a half or
thereabouts and concentration camps,
but when he got out he developed stomach
cancer.
So that's a brief summary of some of the
highlights of his life.
Okay.
In this scene,
he's being transported from one camp to
another.
You know,
a railway car that's being roughly
outfitted for transporting human beings.
He's sitting with the friend that he
calls panic.
I'm just going to read you this story.
My friend pattern and I are lying on the
Middle Shelf of a stall up in
compartment.
That's what it was.
Cattle cars basically to refit it for
human transport and have set ourselves
up comfortably,
talk to our salt carrying in our pocket
so we don't need water and can go to
sleep.
But at some station or other,
they shoved into our compartment.
A Marxist scholar.
We can tell this from his goatee and
spectacles.
He doesn't hide the fact.
So He's been arrested.
He's a devout communist,
being arrested by the communists.
He doesn't hide the fact.
He's a former professor of the
guardianist academy.
We hang head down in the square,
cut out from his very first words.
We see that he is impenetrable,
but we have been serving time for a very
long time and have a long time left to
serve and we value of Mary joke.
We'd was pointing down,
have fun.
There's ample space left in the
compartment.
So we exchanged places with someone and
crowd in.
Hello?
You don't too crowded?
No,
it's all right.
Have you been in the jug a long time?
Long enough or you past the halfway
mark?
Just
look over there.
How poverty stricken her villages are.
Straw thatch,
crooked hugs.
That's an inheritance heritance from the
czarist regime.
What we've already had 30 Soviet years.
That's an insignificant period.
Historic.
It's terrible that the collective
farmers are starving,
but have you look in all the wrappings
just ask any collective farber in
apartment.
Well,
everyone in jail is embittered and
prejudice,
but I've seen collective farms myself.
That means they were uncharacteristic.
The goatee had never been in any of them
that way.
Simpler.
Just ask the old folks and bizarre.
They were well fed,
well clothed,
and they used to have many holidays.
I'm not even going to ask.
It's a subjective trait of human memory
to praise everything in the past.
The cow or the died is the one that gave
twice the milk.
Sometimes even certain problems and
there are people don't like holidays.
They like to work.
Why is there a shortage of brandon?
Many cities when right before the war,
for example,
not true before the war,
everything in fact and be more.
Listen at that time in all the cities on
the pool guy,
they were accused of thousands of
people,
a local failure and supply.
More likely your memory's failing you,
but there this shortage.
Now old wives tales we have from seven
to 8 billion bushels of grain.
The grain is rotten,
not so we've been very successful in
developing new species,
great
and so forth.
He's going to perturb level.
He speaks in the language between
quarters,
no effort of the mind and arguing with
him is like walking through a desert.
It's about people like that,
but they say he made the rounds of all
the blocks smiths and came home on Shawn
and when they write in their obituaries
perished tragically during the period of
the stone in this cult,
it should be corrected to read perished
comically benefits.
Faith had worked out differently.
We would have never learned what a dry,
insignificant little man he really was.
We would have respectfully read his name
in the newspaper.
We would have,
he would have become a people's
commissar or even ventured to represent
the whole Russia abroad.
To argue with him.
It was useless.
It was much more interesting to play
with.
It don't a chess,
but at the game of comrades already is
such a game.
It's very simple game play up to him.
A couple of times or so,
you used some of his own pet words and
phrases.
He'll like that phrase,
grown accustomed to find it all around
him are enemies.
He's become weary of snarling and
doesn't like to tell his stories because
all of them will be twisted and thrown
right back into space.
But if he takes you for one of his own,
he will quite.
Keven only disclosed to you.
What have you seen at the station?
People are passing by talking,
laughing.
Life goes on.
The party is providing leadership.
People are being moved from job to job.
If you and I are languishing here in
prison,
there are only a handful of us and we
must write and write petitions,
begging a review of our cases for a
pardon
or he will tell you something
interesting.
In the Communist Academy,
they decided to devour one program and
he decided he wasn't quite genuine,
one of our own and somehow they couldn't
manage it.
There were no errors in his assets and
his biography was clean and all of a
sudden going through the archives,
what a fine.
They ran across an old brochure written
by his comrade in which Vladimir Ilyich
Lenin himself had held in his hands.
And in the margin of which he had
written in his own handwriting.
The notation has it in the economist is
shit,
well now you understand or smile
essentially,
but after that it's no trouble at all to
make short work of that model.
Hadn't paused.
He was expelled from the academy and
deprived of the scholar.
This story.
That's a perfect example of the kind of
phenomena that I'm interested in trying
to understand.
The communist professor,
this exchange,
he doesn't think,
it doesn't have to think because he has
an ideological system that time it
worked out.
He won't admit
any evidence whatsoever exists to
suggest that some of his presuppositions
are wrong.
For every bit of evidence that exists,
there is a counter argument that
justifies it or excuse it or makes it
disappear in some way.
That's the first part of this story.
The second part of the story is that
being like this,
he's also extraordinarily clannish in a
sense.
Can you tell us a brief story about
being in the Communist Academy where
everyone shares in urology and finding
outside yourself essentially destroyed
there specific reasons why the two
halves of that narrative,
we're stuck together because the first
attitude leads in absorb link to the
second attitude,
which is to say the adoption and
authoritarian etiology,
which is basically the presumption of
omniscience in a sense.
If you're an idiot,
you think that what you think is the
right thing thing.
There isn't anything else that needs to
be thought.
It's you that has the answer.
Now you might know,
thank it's you.
You might even think that it's your
leader or the ideology in and of itself,
but the point is you're the one that's
in possession of the absolute truth in
every fact that might exist to dispute
that is eliminated.
And a problem with the limited facts is
that sometimes they come in and body
form,
which is to say we tend to think of
ideas as disembodied abstract and
entities,
but the truth of the matter is that
ideas are representations of human
patterns of action and sometimes the
enemy idea is actually the enemy.
And there's very little difference from
the practical perspective between
repressing facts that are uncomfortable
and repressing people whose viewpoints
or even styles of existence are equal in
long term.
So this is another example,
this sort of thinking that I want to
explain,
I want to spend the motivation for that.
Why is it that someone would adopt a
rigid ideological position and then
defend it sometimes to their own debt
but more frequently to the death of
others and to feel that not only is that
is that
acceptable,
we'd often even morally justifiable.
It's is the thing that should be done.
You're a good Patriot so just
so
this is the quick thesis.
This is what I want to address and of
course
I don't want to use this.
I said I don't want to take a stab at
the question so to speak.
I don't want to beat around the Bush on
an answer these so that when you're
finished of course you will.
What purpose group identification
serves,
why it's so important to people,
how it developed,
what it means to have a belief.
People have beliefs.
We never really,
a question we get is what it means
when you say that.
I have,
I think the world is in a particular way
as opposed to some other particular way.
Why do we feel threatened?
We were in groups.
We identify with our challenged.
Why does challenge me as aggressive and
righteously and sort of the core.
I guess those are the core questions of
course centers around.
There's more I can describe the whole,
of course.
Obviously it's the first lecture.
This is about half the half the story.
I'm also interested in how our own
personal behaviors make our group
identification more or less dangerous
and what can be done about that as well.
Okay,
so
do you understand why we are capable of
atrocious behavior?
You have to understand how we think and
I want to approach that from a variety
of different perspectives giving you
initially he grounding and mortar neuro
psychology or psychology and emotion and
emotional regulation because that puts
the discussion on what I think is a firm
foundation.
He said I bring in 10 political ideas
and ideas from literature and philosophy
as well,
but it's nice to also have reference to
some facts that are acceptable as facts.
That's when you start,
you know,
psychology well,
how do we think this is half the store?
We'll discuss the other half as we go
through the course.
The course is
predicated on a theory of knowledge.
Let's suggest that we classify objects
in situations according to two separate
types of schemes.
And the first type of scheme is one that
everyone was essentially familiar with
apps.
The scientific scheme that makes the
presupposition that there's an objective
world that's apprehensible to the census
make,
can be collectively describe,
which is only to say that the thing is
real,
if you can sense it,
choose me means if you can touch it or
see it or in some other way detected.
If you can describe the price procedures
by which now detection.
Oh Curd.
And if someone else duplicating those
procedures comes up with this same
observations and that's a real thing and
that's a fact.
It's a scientific fact and we've been
able to codify a methodology for
determining what is from the objective
perspective and I don't think there's,
there's no real reason to dispute that
seems more or less self evident.
It's a relatively new procedure.
We've only been really good at it for
500 years at the most.
It's going to be in that long since the
scientific enterprise is being
transformed into something that was
actually codify.
It's obviously an extraordinary
efficient way to proceed and there's no
point in a sense,
been debating is utility.
That's one type of
knowledge scheme,
but there's another type
that people have spent much less time
formalize it partly because it's more
difficult before we want to say with
regards to the scientific method,
we more or less have a set of agreed
upon rules by which the endeavor should
proceed and also by which to judge the
validity of the outcomes of the
procedures.
You can write them down.
They're very much formalized.
That's why almost anybody can do
scientific research,
especially the type of scientific
research that Tom is tuned described as
normal,
which basically means that you have a
set theory what's you're not trying to
challenge and working with him to theory
to more or less flesh it out,
so a technician putting into work potent
technical tools that you can virtually
do by rote.
Anyways,
we figured out how to formalize that.
That's an answer to the question.
What is,
how to control things.
The second type of inflammation.
That's the type of that I am concerned
in this course and that is not what a
thing is from the objective perspective
but about what it is from the
perspective of determining its
implications for behavior and to say,
well there are things and there is also
knowledge about how to behave in your
presence.
First kind of information you might
consider.
The second kind of inflammation is more
akin to what has been traditionally
described as wisdom because wisdom is
the knowledge of how to conduct
yourself.
Things exist and the fact that their
existence has implications for behavior
and what's the implications of the
existence of things for behavior that I
want to focus on.
Because in our social command it's we
come to agreements over vast stretches
of time about what sorts of behaviors
are to be considered appropriate in
which situations and under which
conditions,
and it's this agreement Atlantans
predictability to our interpersonal
relationships.
It can take an example just of this
course we all share map,
so to speak of what behaviors are
appropriate in a situation like this.
And essentially what that means is that
we can come in here and conduct our
business and we all know what that
business is going to be.
There's no dispute about that and we all
know more or less what our respective
roles are going to be in conducting that
business.
There's no real,
there's no space for disputed at all,
which basically means that our shared
map of the significance of the events
that are occurring in this room
eliminates the need for conflict.
We don't even have,
we don't have fight about what's going
to happen here.
We don't have to fight about who owns
that sunkist orange juice or who's going
to take control of the pens or who owns
that particular computer or who's going
to,
or how the,
how the discussion is going to proceed.
That's all mapped out for us in some
ways and that means that we've rendered
ourselves in this particular situation
predictable,
which means that there's no reason for
any of us to regard any of the other
people in the room with any sort of
apprehension whatsoever.
So in a sense you could say that for me,
you're a fixed object in terms of your
significance in this environment.
And the reason for that is because we're
engaging in a culturally determined
process,
none of which were questioning or at
least that we've,
we've accepted implicitly or explicitly
and implicitly you're out of university.
This is what happens at a university,
you know,
that I know of that we don't have to set
any of the ground.
Well,
it's our shared apprehensions about the
implications of situations for behaviors
that constitute our cultures.
And it's those shared maps that bring
predictability to our interpersonal
relationships.
And what that essentially you can only
understand that if you understand what
the world is like when it's not
predictable.
And it's difficult to understand that
for water and people who live in
peaceful times because our culture is so
successful at regulating our
interpersonal behavior and even the
environment for that matter.
But we hardly ever encounter a situation
where anything remotely unpredictable
happens.
So you can't tell what it's like to be
faced with something that's
unpredictable.
So you don't know what it's like when
you're in an environment where culture
doesn't rain because you're part of a
successful community in your
extraordinarily well protected it.
You're like,
you're like a boy that lives inside the
castle.
You can't see over the walls.
It doesn't even know that they're there
and just all sorts of terrible things
outside the castle.
But everything inside is peaceful and
that's the world and the boy has no idea
what he would be like if he went outside
into the real world where things were
actually not predictable because he's
only had a chance to observe his
behavior under stable conditions where
everything's predictable and acceptable.
It's even worse now in a sense it's
better than waiting too.
I mean he is peaceful now in many ways.
I mean even compared to 15 years ago,
there's much less ideological dispute in
the world about how to conduct affairs.
Then there was staying in the mid
seventies and people are more or less,
I mean I know there's exceptions to
this,
but people in the world over have more
or less accepted in this basket.
For example,
for a market and economy,
there aren't very many ideologies that
appear attractive even in the
imagination in contrast to two western
style democracies and I mean not so
pretty recent occurrence and it's
unlikely to last for any great length of
time,
I think,
but it is peaceful now
that the fact that that piece makes it
even more difficult for us to either to
understand ourselves or to be
sufficiently motivated to understand
yourself because when things are going
really well and everything's
predictable,
then you presume that you know what
you're doing.
In fact,
that's the basis on which you,
you base your judgments about whether
you know what you're doing,
if you perform a procedure and what you
predicted,
oh,
occurs.
You're right.
Now that doesn't mean you know
everything,
but as far as you're concerned,
that's sufficient.
So anyways,
the fundamental point is this.
We share a map of the significance of
things and situations including other
people,
including ourselves and not maps or
culture.
And one of the lines of arguments that I
want to develop throughout the course of
this course is that that shared culture
takes the form of a story.
In fact,
that's what his story is.
A story is a description of the
significance of situations or events for
behavior and the stories.
The kind of inflammation story is a form
of information that transmits abstract
knowledge about how to add.
So you have on the one hand,
scientific descriptions are the
descriptions of facts,
things that are sensory apprehensible to
a collected and you had another form of
information that's narrative and a
narrative contains information,
but how you should conduct yourself
literally how you should propel your
body through space under which
circumstances and the shared narrative
post due to culture.
Yeah.
Let me show you,
but I think the basic structure of a
story,
okay.
Scientific description is concerned with
what is,
can we do?
We have rules for determining a story is
concerned with what is known from the
perspective of the census.
But from the perspective of the
implications for behave.
So that's the main essential things have
an existence.
They have a meaning and the story is
concerned with the meaning and
meaning is a description of the current
state description of the ideal future
state and the description of means of
transformation.
You run a fantasy of the sort of three
so you have a plan,
a plan,
it's relevant to something you
termination of action.
You just want to go down to the corner
store,
get a loaf of bread.
You can see above yourself here as
lacking something necessary,
apprehended in the abstract and an ideal
goal,
which is your trip down to the store and
you also formulating plans of how to get
there and you,
you,
you valuate oh occurrences on the way to
this store in relationship to two year
idealized future.
Just to say that anything that gets in
your way basically on the way to this
store,
if you're in a hurry for example,
that's regarded as an inconvenience.
Anything that hurries you along?
Yes,
regarded it as something positive.
Just basically to say that you use your
apprehension of the ideal future,
which is always construed in
relationship to your present conditions
as the Schema by which you determine the
significance of things.
Because you're always construing the
meaning of things in relationship to
what you want to do in relationship to
this function.
And this basically constitutes the
whole,
the whole story in a sense,
at least the simple version of it.
Okay.
Let me just stop there for a second.
Ask people questions.
And then next thing I want to do is give
you a really brief overview of how your
brain determines how things should be
evaluated in terms of their emotional
relevance.
Okay?
Does anybody have any questions so far
on the other,
the quality,
you put up a,
what is the,
the ring then the Naccho though.
The,
the gang run,
right?
Is that,
that the bring the neck of the right or
wring the neck of the people that are
under the,
uh,
under the federation.
It was the cup like that,
that poem was it.
It's by a poet,
I think his name was [inaudible] sst of
eliminating descent.
So like there's this,
you could think the Soviet Union,
for example,
ran on a number of five year plans,
five year plans where we're going to,
we are here,
we're going to get to here.
Here are the means by which that's going
to be done.
Then anybody who was viewed as deviated
from that plan,
of course,
was instantly regarded as a threat and
my costs in the same luck,
those are the gang run,
right?
And fundamentally anybody who doesn't
agree with the forward portion of the
current society instantly regarded well.
They're instantly regardless,
fundamentally hasn't it normally,
but more pragmatically as a threat.
And my costco was making the point that
those people,
they should be eliminated.
They deserve to be eliminated,
which is even,
you know,
even a further step in a sense,
they constitute the class of things that
deserves to be annihilated because it's
construed in relationship to some ideal.
At the same.
You might be wondering,
why the hell was this a story?
What does this have to do with the
story?
While I can give you the most,
the most fundamental example of the
census.
I want to tell you what stories are and
then I want to take a look at their
substructure.
Well,
the fact that there's a substructure to
stories as evidence in the number of
subtle ways,
it's part of the epidemic because
myths that have been collected
throughout the world have a remarkably
similar nature.
That's one,
one bit of information that's relatively
curious.
It's also very strange,
but the people like stories.
Children will listen to stories and come
to any external reinforcement.
They're intrinsically rewarding.
People Watch tv all the time because TV
is full of stories.
We pay to go see movies more by normals,
but something about stories that are
intrinsically attractive to the point
that will actually work to be allowed to
becoming,
to be in contact with them,
which should beg the question.
Since we're willing to go to all that
trouble,
to,
to look at stories and to receive them,
perhaps they're actually serving some
function.
It seemed at least at least reasonable
in the function.
There's certainly
story.
Good story is what regulates your
emotions.
And if you share a story with someone
else,
then you can predict them and both your
emotions are making a group of you share
the store,
then you have the culture and you're all
more or less predictable to one another.
It's a very useful because then you can
be organized and you could move forward
in one direction and so on.
But most of your predictable tomorrow
say
shoe to make the story aspect of this
more comprehensible.
You might think of this as political
utopia.
That's one way of doing it or as a
vision of paradise.
And then that's the archetypical aspect
of underlies the notion that the future
could in fact be better than the
present.
Even in trivial waste.
We're doing this all the time.
We're always moving from a state that we
can see them as not entirely ideal
towards a state,
that we can see them even in the
smallest ways as somehow better than
where we work.
And that's the sort of thing in fact,
gives us the impetus to move forward in
the,
in a literal sense.
But underlying that is the notion way
under so to speak is the notion that the
world as it is presently constructed is
somehow we needed redemption and there
is a state hypothetical state that
exists somewhere in the future,
so to speak,
or somewhere at least towards which the
world could move in all religious
stories,
all religious systems share that sort of
notion of clinical that you told use as
well.
I mean it's really evident in the case
of something like,
Connie,
this is call me.
This was always trying to establish
the Kingdom of God on earth,
so to speak.
Although of course without theoretically
without the religious overtones,
it of course we've just made implicit
instead of instead of being allowed to
be,
to be explicit because Stellan was as
close to a god and a pretty miserable
one is any religion hasn't managed to
construct.
This isn't a simple story.
Basically stories have a slightly more
complicated structure than this,
which we'll discuss later.
How would you distinguish or how do you
distinguish between the strategy and the
story?
This would be a strategy in here.
A strategy is just,
that's a good question.
This is actually,
this is somewhat simpler then the real
structure because in a sense each of
these strategies is this whole structure
in a smaller sense.
So you could say this structure is
composed of smaller units like this all
the way down and I don't know how far
down I'm being able to figure that out,
but like because every goal can be
conceptualized as viewed of sub goals
that have the same notion for for the
purposes of the present discussion.
This is a sufficient sufficient
representation,
but that's something will that specific
issue we'll talk about more in the
latter part of the latter part of the
course because the fact that a story is
made up of sub stories right down to the
lowest level of resolution has
implications for all for certain forms
of mythological representations,
representations of trees actually
knowing and want to get into that at the
moment.
So anyways,
that's the story you said.
I put up there the domain and
constituent elements of the known what
you pay for,
kind of,
I don't want a title for our diagram
like this,
but I would say that from the
perspective of the regulation of
emotion,
a story about where you are and where
you'd like to get to and how are you
going to do that?
That is what you know,
just remember,
we're not in the domain of facts here
construed from the scientific
perspective.
We're in the domain of wisdom,
behavioral knowledge and what you know
is where you are,
where you want to be,
and theoretically how to get there.
So
I'll explain this in some more detail
later.
Yeah.
Oh sure.
I'm,
yeah.
Okay.
So I said the first thing we're going to
do,
it's described in some detail how the
brain works and I want to do that
because I want to give you some insight
into how it is that we processed the
multiple information and you need to
know,
and we think in stories before you can
actually understand how it is that we
processing emotional information.
So I'm going to put up a somewhat
complicated diagram.
Your number basically that it will take
three weeks to discuss this case
briefing,
but here's,
here's the ideal.
It's not as complicated as it looks.
Okay?
At the top,
well this is a circle but and you can
start anywhere in a circle,
but we'll start at the top is how you
process information.
Obviously the bottom line is if you have
a certain road,
Spencer,
again,
okay.
That seems where you input is
interpreted with regards to a
significance as a consequence of its
interaction with what you already know,
which is basically to say that your
presence,
which is which constitutes the sensory
information you ready for you to Tim
pinching on you at this moment is not a
vertical picture of the external world,
but your interpretation of reality as
it's unfolding.
And I'm not saying I'm not trying to
make a point that there no such thing as
an external reality or that you living
in a delusion or any of those things,
just that you're always interpreting
what's going on in relationship to its
significance to you and you have models,
some models.
Then you're doing that.
You have theories about what someone's
like,
what you're like and what the situation
consists of,
what you should be doing next.
If all of the input did you have with
prostitutes,
your online experience is a function of
your interpretation.
It's based on actual information,
but it's still a function of
interpretations.
Okay,
let's,
we'll use your declarative memory.
That's one form of memory storage to
construct your version of the present.
That's the significance of things as
they're unfolding at the present time,
and you can only really,
you can only really make judgments about
the significance of things by contrast
with what you would like to happen.
That's your image of them.
Have the desired future.
Okay?
If you're,
if you're doing something this evening,
it's a very simple,
well,
let me give you an example.
There are experiments where people's
task is to pick up an object and you
could see the object in front of them.
Okay,
so you're giving the tasks.
That's the basic story.
The story is what you're required to do
is to transform yourself from the person
you are now into the person who has
possession of the watch.
It's just the standard laboratory
experiment,
but the watch is actually there.
It's an image that's generated by
mirrors and when you move towards the
watch,
you find that it's not where it appears
to be.
Well,
the fact of object not being where it
appears to be is an anomaly with regards
to your current plan and you'll react to
that emotional.
The first thing that'll happen is that
obviously you're going to be surprised,
right?
You think this is pretty easy.
I'm going to pick that up and you find
out that the thing that you see is no,
it actually there.
That's an anomaly you contrast and your
desired future,
which was your aim when you moved your
arm with the actual outcome of your
actions.
That's a mismatch.
So part of your brain called the
hippocampus that seems to be responsible
for comparing what's actually going on
in so far as you can interpret that with
what you want to happen and if,
if a mismatch occurs,
that sets up a whole sequence of related
events and those events manifest
themselves in emotion and in thought and
in behavior most evidently and emotion.
If you're going to do something,
you've done it before and it doesn't
work out the way you expected it to.
The events that constitute the anomaly,
the unexpected occurrence there are
surprising.
And the question then is what does
surprising me?
Well,
it basically means that
something threatening as occurred and
something,
something that moon is taking place.
And what does the unknown mean?
Well,
the thing about the unknown is that you
don't know what it means.
It's pretty,
it's a pretty straightforward statement,
but you see that immediately.
That immediately introduces this strange
sort of paradox because you lacked
infinite information.
Obviously people don't know what they're
doing all the time,
which means that you come into contact
with things that you'd want to
understand the law.
And that means in the sense that you
have to know what to do when you don't
know what to do because you don't know
what to do a lot and that just doesn't
just bring into a hall.
What is the case that your nervous
system is hardwired to move to a sort of
default position when the plans that the
explicit plan is that you have,
that you're carrying out fail.
So as long as you could say in a sense,
as long as you know what you're doing,
which means that you have a
representation of where you are and
where you'd like to be,
you're carrying out your plans to make
the move and things are going according
to plan.
As long as you're doing that,
then the higher centers in your,
of your brain and the cortex basically
it's under control.
You know what you're doing.
If you feel comfortable and secure as
soon as something unexpected happens,
the control shifts and this is something
that basically beyond your capacity to
control,
well you can interfere with the process
control shifts from the cortical centers
to the more fundamental areas of the
brain.
To the limbic system.
When something unexpected happens,
two things,
Bowker,
you stop,
you'll feel a little bit of anxiety and
it's not unexpected you occurrences,
it's really unexpected.
You will be very,
very frightened because just minor
something,
minor league,
unexpected.
He'll just stop.
Your sensory processing will heighten,
you'll gather more information and
you'll explore and as you explore the
generate information and the information
is supposed to bring me back on course
basically.
So you'll say
what you'll do if you're trying to reach
for the watch and you can find out that
it isn't where you taking this call,
you'll start making different sorts of
approach sequences until you end up
producing.
Now tell me that you intended
when something unexpected occurs,
two sets of circuitry,
you're activated.
One looks like it's dominated by the
right hand to secure the other.
It looks like it's dominated by the left
hemisphere.
Unexpected things make you anxious and
curious and you've been localize those
emotions in the body,
so to speak.
Anxiety is the emotion that a company is
the cessation of your body's plan
directed activities.
Okay?
That's you could say that anxiety is
what you feel when you slipped into the
motive.
Pause,
pause for further analysis.
What do you expect it to do?
Give you a copy so you have to stop.
Curiosity is what you feel when it's
necessary for you to explore further,
to gather new information,
to update your plans and exploration is
basically governed by the interplay of
the circuitry brain circuitry that
mediates anxiety and curiosity.
Curiosity,
by the way,
now it's associated with positive
emotions and anxiety.
As you all know.
Those associated with to negative people
shooting people would rather do I
experience it.
Curiosity of course.
Surprise is basically a juxtaposition of
those two sets of emotions which work
antagonistically.
The unknown produces coin flipped all by
itself.
That's thick.
It's in a sense,
it's kind of early to introduce this,
but that's the central theme in a way of
the whole course is that you have a hard
wired response to the emergence of the
unexpected.
You have to because they have to know
what to do with something unexpected
trip.
It's instinct.
Your instinct of response to the
unknown.
Anxiety plus curiosity,
which is to say cessation of ongoing
motor activity plus a drive to move
forward and explore and your exploratory
activities.
Actually the sum total of the activation
of the two sets of circuitry that
mediate that response and when you
explore,
if you explore,
if something unexpected happens,
you don't have to explore,
you can note it and get the hell out of
there.
It's safe,
but you don't get them any new
information.
It's a good short term strategy.
It's not a good long term strategy,
but anyways,
the point is,
is that surprise,
it's curiosity and it tells you 40
generate new information,
you update your plan,
and as soon you can get to her,
you want to go.
The point is the mismatch between what
you expect to happen and what actually
happens.
That disc inhibits thing side.
Yeah.
If mismatch occurs,
there's a little sub organ in your brain
called the Amygdala and you made,
it looks like it's responsible for the
addition of emotion to sensory
experience.
Yeah.
Behavioral psychologists have presumed
in the past,
most psychologists presume particularly
behaviors that you learned to be afraid.
Newer models of the neuropsychology of
volition reversed that precept position
and say,
no.
You know how to be afraid.
Anything that you don't expect makes you
afraid.
That's your default position.
What you have to learn is how to be
secure.
Now,
by the time you're an adult,
you've learned how to be secure so well
under most circumstances,
under secure circumstances,
you've learned how to be secure so well.
Then you don't realize that you're a
priority or default position is fear.
You're coming,
you're so well inculturated,
assuming you're successful.
That's the true nature of your emotional
responses in is in a sense hidden from
you,
which is precisely as it's supposed to
be because the whole purpose of
socialization,
the whole purpose of learning is in fact
to shut off the circuitry that says
something of indeterminant significance
is occurring now.
People do not like it,
will not.
Certain three is accurate,
don't not,
not it.
That's a fit in the air because people
like to explore.
You're like novelty in small doses,
small controllable doses.
It's like food.
It's when something truly unexpected
occurs that up roots or upsets your
plans,
that anxiety really becomes
disinhibited.
People like that less than anything
else.
Anyways,
the Amygdala labels things that are
unexpected as simultaneous,
that threatening and promised,
that basically puts you into an
approach.
Avoidance conflict.
So what does that mean?
It means that anything unpredictable is
not neutral.
Anything unpredictable was frightened
that that in and of itself immediately
she has a certain amount of life of why
is that we're somewhat low to accept
people whose behaviors we can't predict
it as one of us people who are from a
culture that's different from ours for
example,
who have a story about how things should
go that runs differently from ours.
Their behavior cannot be predicted with
certainty and you,
you're,
you are instinctively wired so to speak,
to label unpredictable behavior as
threatened.
And I think you can think about this in
really concrete terms and you can
experience this sort of thing regularly.
For example,
on a stroll through Harvard Yard in
north.
Like if you look around you,
you're all decked out in symbols.
So does that indicate here a particular
status?
And Gold direct nature in a community
such as this,
you're all relatively well dressed,
you're all relatively,
no,
it's all it's intended.
Um,
you're all weld grew,
you're a tentative and your behavior is
very much indistinguishable from one
another.
They're all participating in the same
sort of ritual.
And then there's,
there's no reason for you to view your
neighbor's sitting beside you with any
degree of suspicion because you're
convinced that you can predict them.
But if you take a walk through somewhere
like Harvard Square,
where there are people who in a sense
fallen out of the culture.
So there are people there who were
mentally ill,
some of them are schizophrenia,
many other miracle holic or homeless for
one reason or another.
They're hard on your guilt if nothing
else,
but they're also unpredictable.
And you find that people do standard
things in the face of unpredictable.
Others,
they tend to avoid them,
walk around them,
or at least to feel very uncomfortable
in your presence.
And that's because you do not know what
to do in the face of someone who's story
you cannot easily determine.
You don't know what they're like.
You don't know if they're going to hurt
you.
You don't know if they're,
um,
if they're,
if they're dangerous.
In some regards,
you don't know what your obligations are
with regards to them.
They're already labeled as part of the
unknown,
so to speak,
and you'll give them a relatively wide
berth.
Okay?
The only message that that's really
necessary from this particular slide,
you're always contrast what you want to
happen with what you think is that
they're both more and wherever there's a
deviation,
wherever what you want to happen isn't
going on,
then you feel anxiety,
curiosity as well here impelled to
explore.
But anxiety is the thing that comes up
first.
And the larger,
the magnitude of the unexpected
occurrence,
the greater the amount of anxiety.
One of the things we're going to try to
determine in the courses,
how you can understand how large a
disruption a given unexpected event is.
Because,
you know,
minor thing,
let's go back to the southern diner for
a second.
Here's a,
here's a way of looking at it.
So let's say you're,
you know,
you're going somewhere,
you have three plans to get there and
this one doesn't work.
So that means it produces an outcome
that isn't what you envisioned and this
plan doesn't work.
It produces a anomalous outcomes as
well,
but that plan doesn't work well,
that's no problem.
And he knows are pretty minor league
disruptions.
All you do is you keep the same vision
of yourself and the same vision of the
future.
You just switched between plants and
you're really in trouble if none of your
plans work or if someone messes around
with your representation of this or
this.
So you can say for example,
you want to get into medical school and
you need 30 courses to get into medical
school and you should have a's on all of
them and you get a b plus on one course.
Okay,
well you still have all these other
courses.
That's not such a big deal.
It's a minor league disruption that
causes you a certain amount of anxiety
and produces a certain amount of
exploratory behavior.
Perhaps might go to the professor and
say,
why is it that I got this last one?
I was expecting a name.
Don't you know what that's going to do
that by positioning of the ideal future
and so on and so forth.
That's,
that's one sort of disruption.
You're a bit anxious,
but hey,
you have 29 other courses,
it's not such a big deal.
Now instead write damn cap and You score
in the 50th percentile.
Well now you're in trouble because you
have a vision of yourself.
You think this is your version of the
unbearable present.
You know,
a doctor that's a pain in the neck,
but you're a potential doctor.
You have the intellectual resources at
your disposal and the educational
background and,
and,
and the familial,
uh,
push perhaps to make you into a doctor.
And so that's what you've conceived
yourself as.
That's your story about yourself cause
you're the,
this person with this set number of
potentials.
And you also have the visual of where it
is that you're going,
oh,
am cat score comes back and you're in
the 15th percentile.
Well your,
your ideal future is gone.
That's a big problem because that means
that all of the events that have
surrounded you and surround you now and
as far back as you can remember that
were given determinant significance by
this particular plan have all been cast
into chaos.
Everything that you've done up to that
point has been predicated on the notion
that this is where you were going and
that means that the significance that
you attributed to everything was
attributed to everything in relationship
to that goal.
You blow out the goal and all those
significance or backup in the air.
We have to modify your version of
yourself.
Why the hell are you going to do now
they going to be a doctor,
but a lot of work into this.
Plus it's your whole self conception.
Well,
this is gone.
This is gone.
I mean this is irrelevant,
right?
I mean the other 29 courses,
why the hell are you even here now?
That's one example of the levels at
which anomalies can incur minor league
anomalies.
No problem.
You just scoot around them and you go to
the same place,
major league anomalies.
It's a new ideal future.
That's part of the reason that people
are so prone to ideological conflicts.
It's like this is an ideology.
You could say it has a particular
version of the way things are.
Knowing a little bit communist ideology
is pretty,
it's pretty explicit.
What's the unbearable present,
so to speak?
Well,
I know this is a bit dated,
but we're running out of the hardline
etiologies to co fund,
so I have to use an old one.
But um,
the unbearable present is the class
struggle and we have reasons for that.
It's basically the fault of the rich who
are exploiting the poor.
The ideal future is the point at which
those unfair divisions of capital are
eliminated them.
There's a whole bunch of means to that
end.
That's,
that's an ideology.
Well,
someone else has a different ideology,
different version of the significance of
current events,
a different version of the significance
and the nature of the ideal future and
they completely different apprehension
of how to transform one or the other.
When those two cultures come into
contact,
we'll how,
first of all,
they made each other anxious because
they're not convinced.
They don't have to answer and goals.
And if this is the structure that
regulates emotion,
well what's going to happen?
Why don't you can't just give up your
damn plans because then your emotions
are dysregulated.
You fall into chaos,
so to speak.
You don't know where you are and you
don't know who you are.
You don't know what to do and you don't
know where you're going.
That makes you anxious.
Neither side is going to give up.
Give up their certainty.
Well,
the only thing left and under what
circumstances is conflict and you see
this,
I mean look how do,
how do arguments escalate and argue?
Argument with someone that you love.
Even if they want one thing,
you want another,
you discuss it.
You're not getting anywhere you're
tempers raise because the abstract
discussion isn't helping find that you'd
give up.
Maybe you move to to violence to solve
your problem,
to hammer out the story,
so to speak.
You can do that,
but still oppressing the person who has
the different,
a different import.
So your brain is set up to contrast a
vision of what you would like with a
vision of what's occurring and when
something unexpected occurs and there's
a whole sequence that emotional
processes that are disinhibited,
the May deal with the governors governs.
Then by all appearances.
It's an extraordinarily ancient Oregon
works in concert with the hippocampus.
They hit the campus by the way evolved
in the course of five.
The genesis basically what amphibians
left the ocean.
So we had this circuitry has been around
a long time,
a lot longer than your higher cortical
centers.
It's very sophisticated and it's very
powerful and I think you could say that
we spend our whole lives trying to make
sure that the Amygdala is shut off so we
don't like it when it's on.
I mean,
maybe you can,
that's again,
that's not exactly true because I think
a tiny bit of activation under
controlled circumstances,
that's optimal,
but there's a threshold and if,
and if differs to some degree from
person to person,
if you exceed that threshold,
there's nothing that you dislike more
cause the [inaudible] to the thing that
says everything that you are is in
danger.
We'd like to keep it shut off.
Most of the time it shut off as long as
we associate with people who are
predictable to us,
as long as we know where we're going and
things that we predict our own current,
it shuts up and the cortical centers are
in control and you know,
we go down the path that we've chosen.
Okay.
Now
the other thing I'm interested in is
good.
Say It as far as your brain's concerned.
Yeah.
Let me step one step back.
What's the emotion?
Emotion is the subjective sensation that
you feel when you encounter a situation
that has implications for action.
So emotion occupies the space between
sensory input and motor.
So if you encounter something that has
significance,
you feel an emotion and an emotion is
the subjective sense that it companies
the activation or the preoccupation of
motor output systems.
That's basically how it occurred.
How it appears.
Say Well,
okay,
you can think of the world the way that
we normally think of it as something
that exists objectively have something
that's amenable to scientific
description or you can also think of it
as a place that's full of things that
have implications for rashes.
Now
as far as stories are concerned,
the university is a place that's full of
things that have implications for
action.
That's the environment from the
narrative perspective.
The most fundamental substructure of
narratives can be phoning myths and the
next thing I want to show you is how
miss fundamentally represent the world
in so far as it's conceived of it as
something that has implication for
behavior,
something with emotional significance.
So you decided the world of the
scientific object,
so to speak,
is devoid of emotional significance
really by design.
Part of what you do in the scientific
procedure is eradicate anything that's
purely subjective,
like emotion.
If you think a theory is true because
you liked the theory that snoring
sufficient grounds for considering a
true from the scientific perspective,
you're supposed to make yourself on
objective,
which basically means to eradicate your
emotional assessment of the,
of,
of a given situation.
But the thing is we're always assessing
situations for their athletic.
That significance.
We have to do that because emotion
around affect needs how to act,
and you always have to figure out how to
act in every situation,
so it's reasonable to construe the
world.
That's something that has meaning as a
place where that meaning exists.
This is how the world is conceived of
from the mythological perspective.
Okay.
It's quite straight forward.
I'm not going to talk much about this.
Mythological representation of chaos is
just the attempt to represent the place
that everything comes from before
there's any divisions between any,
I didn't want to get into that right now
from the mythological perspective.
This is,
this is how the world,
this is a creation myth.
Basically you're Rachel things into two
components,
one of which is the unknown and the
other,
which is the known.
Now the no one has this structure.
It's a story is if you know something,
you know the story that goes along with
which means that if you know,
if you know a territory,
if you explore the territory,
I mean as you know how to act,
then that's all.
That's all that I'm trying to emphasize
here and myth.
From the mythological perspective,
the world is constructed of three
things.
One is all those things that you don't
know as the domain of that unpredictable
and it has a primary motivational
significance.
It's basically,
it means that Oh,
first dawn attack,
it scares the hell out of you and then
it makes you curious.
If you stick around long enough.
First face it reveals is the one that
makes you anxious.
That's unexplored territory.
That's the the dark forest,
barbarian lands,
dark water,
the land of the dead tie math as well.
[inaudible] the dragon from Mesopotamian
creation myth from which everything
comes.
Basically
anything frankly,
anything threatening,
anything that makes you run away,
anything that's in the dark,
anything that's unfamiliar,
I don't know what constitutes the
unknown from the mythological
perspective,
that's half the world.
It's a division between chaos and order.
Basically from the mythological
perspective,
that's what the universe is composed of.
Chaos is divided for mortar and that's
the world you live in order.
Hopefully chaos surrounds you like a,
like in the ocean surrounds an island.
Fundamentally.
That's what this diagram is basically
trying to represent the known a great
father.
That's culture,
the village,
the nation explored territory,
the city,
the family,
the king,
the predictable.
That's where you live.
That's where everything is being
transformed from chaos into order where
everything can be predicted and it sits
on top of the unknown.
Psychoanalytic interpretations of
the rationale for social conflict,
often positive that what you see in
people who you are willing to persecute
his,
your own dark side.
Those things above you that you're most
unwilling to admit.
I think there's a certain amount of
truth in that,
but what's more accurate and more
fundamental and much less difficult to
understand in a sense is that
if someone is not familiar to you,
you don't have to presume anything about
the mere fact of their existence as
something unfamiliar.
It's already sufficient to give them a
certain emotional valence and that
emotional valence,
at least on initial contact is the
promotion of anxiety.
Don't.
You don't
have to think in some ways about the
necessity of projection or your unreal
are you're,
you're,
you're only incomprehensibility to
yourself or your propensity did until we
see the evil and others is the mere fact
of unpredictabilities enough to render
someone associated with this domain that
makes the thing
I said we classify things in two
different plays in a sense what caused
to buy things from the scientific
perspective,
but we also classify them from the
perspective of their significance for
action and you could say that a natural
category is the class of all things that
you should run away from and from the
perspective of that sort of
classification,
everything that is the sort of thing
that you should run away from is the
same thing.
So that means anytime you,
you encounter something that's
unpredictable,
it's that thing is instantly thrown into
the category of all the things that I've
ever frightened you,
all the things in your life that you
haven't been able to control because the
idea of the thing that you should run
away from is one of the most fundamental
types of classification.
The ribs just,
we're always classifying things in terms
of fundamental significance for
behavior.
I found out for example,
I'd thought about that,
I guess about six or seven years ago,
I was reading missy Elliot.
There are many creative,
many creation.
There's the world comes out of the body
of a drag.
For example,
in the Mesopotamian creation myth,
marvel versus timeout.
Timeout is a dragon who lives at the
bottom of the ocean and she's the mother
of all the gods,
but they make a lot of noise and
irritate your and it also killed her
husband.
This makes it quite mad,
so she decided she's going to eat them
all and one of the medicine it can go up
to the Martech
is elected by.
The other goal is to go and fight with
time.
Map him down.
He encloses her in a Gnat and cuts or
into pieces.
None of the pieces he makes the world.
He creates
order from chaos.
He's the third feature of the
mythological world.
There's the unknown and there's the no,
and there's process that mediates
between turns.
One backs the hero,
the hero.
He turns up the dragon and makes the
world so he's assimilated to a creator.
God.
Basically.
The reason I'm telling you the story now
of always because I found out from
Iliad,
but many archaic cultures,
the Iranians and the Egyptians were
three others whose names I don't
remember a moment.
The symbol that they used for the
stranger,
the barbarian was the same symbol used
to represent the chaos that predated the
construction of the world.
So you can,
this is so interesting.
If you'd grab the Chris Grasp the
significance of that because it meant
that Egyptian,
the ancient Egyptians,
for example,
who never let a foreigner into one of
their temples because the foreigner
would bring chaos into order.
The forerunner was chaos.
That's the thing for the Egyptian
foreigner was chaos.
They use the same symbol.
That's how people think that is.
We think it's like if you're not from
the same tribe,
however,
that's defined most,
most fundamentally,
it would be the family,
but obviously we've abstracted that up
into the nation.
We're into an ideological unit or
whatever.
If you're not us,
then you are chaos and all by yourself.
Under those circumstances.
If you're an agent of chaos,
you have emotional significance.
Here's something I know I can't predict.
I'm afraid of things I can't predict.
You're a threat to me.
Along the path from that to to
oppressing you is not very,
very,
it's a very short one.
Well,
one of the things we're going to study
to a fair degree is mythological
representations of the world hits.
I find this extremely interesting and
the reason for this is because as soon
as you know,
as soon as you know that we use stories
to regulate our emotions,
and as soon as you know that there are
two types of information that we need to
gather,
one be factual information and the other
information about how we should behave,
then you have the possibility of reading
mythological accounts or stories in
general from a completely different
perspective because you don't have to
think anymore.
Well,
this mythological account,
for example,
with the creation of the world has no
relationship whatsoever to evolutionary
theory.
We know evolutionary theories more
accurate,
therefore this whole sequence,
but accounts has to be cast into the
realm like pseudoscience of
superstition.
Well then you lose all the information
that's in those stories.
As soon as you know that those stories
aren't concerned in the least with the
construction of the objective world,
but our concern with the world as it as
it has significance women,
you have a whole new way of approaching
the whole new mode of interpreting them
and you can start to understand the
nature of the stories that actually
underlie our culture and believe me,
that's so,
that's so useful.
Well,
it's so useful.
You can hardly believe it.
Fine.
All of a sudden there's all these
stories that you've heard since the
earliest days.
Stories that are basically rationally
and comprehensible.
As soon as you twist your
presuppositions about their origins,
just 45 degrees,
then you can see the order in the mini
exactly what it is that they're trying
to turn to put forth and they all of a
sudden made sense.
Well,
I think knowing,
just regardless of its implications for
Social Poncelet,
knowing that getting a key to the
meaning of the stories that's worth
having to plow your way through all the
information that you have to read in
this course because you all Italian,
you'll go see if they can see movies and
read novels and look at myths and we'll
think,
oh,
I know what that means now,
isn't it?
Isn't it so interesting?
If that's what it means,
you can immediately see that
relationship between the story and your
own and the position that you occupy in
the midst of things.
It's very fascinating.
So we're interested in representation,
but right here,
I want to read you a bit of a story
here.
So the unknown is the great,
terrible mother.
Wow.
You know,
you're going to have to accept that,
my word for that at the moment.
But the basic notion is a feminine
imagery.
10 is tends to be used to represent the
unknown.
And the reason for that is because the
unknown is the mother of all things.
So that's obviously their mystical way
of thinking about it.
But all I've seen is this,
every bit of as far as math is
concerned,
information is the world.
That's the note.
All the information that you generate,
you generate in contact as a consequence
of your contact with something you
didn't understand,
which is only to say that you generate
information by exploring.
It's not hurting.
That's obvious then it's not much of a
step from there to the construing the
thing that you're investigating,
which is the unknown as the source of
everything.
Perfectly reasonable presupposition and
it's not such a difficult leap to make,
to construe the source of everything as
something feminine thing,
something that gives birth to things
anyways.
It doesn't matter if you follow that
train of logic or north or if you accept
that that isn't the case and that is how
miss tend to represent them.
No.
So uh,
one of the books that you're going to
read is called the great mother and
that's how work by your new one and it
is.
It's 300 pages of description of
mythological representations of the
feminine.
Anyways,
that's the mythological aspect.
I want to read you a good story about
rats because I want to show you how
deeply grown with these sorts of notions
are.
I want to tell you a little story first
before I read this,
I was watching a bugs bunny cartoon the
other day with my kids.
And um,
you're probably more or less familiar
with the bugs bunny cartoon characters.
There's a sheep dog and a wolf and they
go to work in the morning and sheepdogs
job is to guard the sheep and the wolves
job is to eat them and they punch the
time,
clock in and then they go into their
respective roles.
Anyways,
the sheep dog is always beating,
whoa,
flop baggy and he gets the real rough
end of the stick.
Now there's one scene there,
cause she'd be August,
sitting on a cliff watching the sheep
and it's raining and the wolf gets a
bright idea,
is going to put hair tonic on the sheet
goes,
hey,
okay.
And it's raining so that the sheep dog,
well not as sweet,
sneaks up and the sheep Harriton and
hair grows down over his eyes right now.
So the sheep dog sitting here and
they're wolf climbs up the cliff and the
first thing he does is he has a hand,
the glove on the stick.
So he's hiding behind the cliff and it
puts the hand on his dick and he raised
it in front of the sheep dog space.
No one response.
Now that wolf is exploring unexplored
territory and it does.
It cautiously sticks a stick on it.
Nothing happens.
And so then the next thing it has is
just pokes his head up and goes right
down and it looks nothing terrible
happens.
And then it climbs up on top of the
cliff and it weighs this hand in hand.
The sheep,
you are you starting to smile now?
I thinks it's pretty smart now it's
jumping up and down.
Okay,
so it's explored the territory.
It's mapped it originally the unexplored
territory was anxiety provoking the wolf
on your way to a whole sequence of
exploratory activities.
Map The territory.
It's safe.
So then it's off to steal a sheep.
Okay,
that's funny.
That was funny because animators are
great at picking out what we do and
exaggerating them.
So they're comical.
That's exploring unknown territory.
Okay.
Most of the time when behavioral
psychologist teach a rat to be afraid
and that's what they think they're
doing,
they take a route that's secure.
So they presumed that the natural state
of the rat is secure.
But the only bloody reason the rats
secure is because it's already explored
his cage.
So you put a rat in a cage and they will
freeze because it's scared.
And then if nothing terrible happens
soon it unfreezes and then it slowly
starts to explore it.
It might just move his eyes first and
sniff and then if not in terrible
happens and starts to move and as soon
and checks out the whole cage.
And if nothing is in there that it's
going to kill it,
it has a nap or whatever.
Maybe it looks for some food,
but it asked to explore before it's
secure.
Now more modern animal psychologist need
fallen,
just sort of starting to study the
reactions of things like rats in their
natural habitat.
And that's what this story is about.
So take a rabbit,
wraps their social,
set them up in a Burl,
and they let them set up.
There were only map out their territory
by exploring.
So they have this whole burl system set
up and the rats,
no,
it,
nothing's dangerous there,
that's home,
but a caffeine,
one section of it.
That's the story.
When a cat is presented to an
established mixed sex group of
laboratory rats living in visible girl,
the behaviors of the subjects changed
dramatically in many cases for 24 hours
or more.
The initial act of defensive behavior
flight to the tunnel chamber system.
So the rats are cruising alone where
they think it's safe and there's a cat.
Well,
it's like home into the borough
is followed by a period of immobility
during which the rats make 22 kilohertz,
ultrasonic vocalization,
which apparently served as lawyer cries
that I rate.
So there to put it,
uh,
they're freaked out and they brought it
home and screen the frozen and they
screen like they must be screaming
something like,
oh no,
there's a cat and all the other grads
here this,
and they're all in their girls.
They're terrifying.
They're frozen into your mobility by the
appearance of this unexpected thing as
freezing breaks up.
It's interesting.
Think of a good myth.
This persons in the Gorgon
show,
the face of the Gorgon was this female
head.
This covered the snakes.
That's a new image of the unknown.
That thing turns you to stone anyways,
as freezing breaks up.
Proxemic avoidance of the open area,
gravity diddly gives way to a pattern of
risk assessment of the area where the
cat was encountered.
Okay,
so the rats are frozen and they think
you know,
oh no,
death is around the corner.
They don't precisely think that,
but that's how they act and if nothing
happens,
it's also terrible.
Well,
they start to relax a little bit and as
soon as they start to relax the circuit,
you're like,
they're very curious about this
unexpected occurrence,
but they're overwhelmed by anxiety.
They don't do any exploring.
They run back and make sure that nothing
terrible happens.
Just like that movie she could dog may
run back and how's their anxiety?
Receipts.
Okay.
Curiosity starts to predominate.
So they go back to the open area subject
to poke their heads out of the tunnel,
openings to scan the open area where the
cat was presented for minutes or hours
before emerging.
So they're like watching this is new
territory now.
There was not supposed to be a cap
there.
So let's just see what happens.
So they're watching in Washington
remapping the territory when they do
emerge there locomotory patents or
characterize while they couldn't have
run flat so they can't be seen.
But the thing that's really neat is they
do short corner runs.
I think this is so interesting.
So you think here's the area the calf
was seen.
Okay,
so it's like
cat
right now,
the rats on the cat there.
So this is,
this is all of a sudden being reading
novelized.
This area was once map and made secure.
But the appearance of the cap there is
throwing their plans for a loop.
So one of the routes do,
well the catch disappeared,
but they don't trust this area anymore
because it was associated with the cat.
So they do corner rugs.
The bravest of rats leaps out of his
title.
And Bratton was right across a small
area and if if he doesn't get killed,
that's safe,
so then it grows back.
It takes not choke up safe.
Other rats are in the same place soon if
there's no cat.
Hilarious mapped.
Again,
these risk assessment areas appear to
involve active gathering information
about possible dangerous sources
providing a basis for a gradual return
to non defensive bt active risk
assessment has not seen during early
post cat exposure but rises to a peak
about 10 hours later.
These rats are scared.
Non Defensive behaviors such as eating,
drinking sexually aggressive activity
tend to be reduced over the same period.
That's because of the anxiety system
just predominance.
You don't think about anything else when
there's a cab around,
so it's such a great,
it's such a great story because you get
an idea of how their Massey University
is set up like there was known territory
and then there's on unknown territory
and well known and known territory can
turn into unknown territory as soon as
something unpredictable happens and when
something unpredictable happens.
That hilarious is made novel again and
the rats have to undergo is very complex
pattern of exploratory activity to make
their territory secure again.
So that's,
that's quite interesting.
It was also the case.
Yeah.
Like I gave you here a representation of
novelty.
That's what normal people,
it's half threat to me produces anxiety,
taft promise and impels exploratory
activity.
Anxiety comes up first.
This has be known among behavioral
psychologists for about five decades.
It's like
the exploratory and anxiety circuitry
are mutually inhibitory,
but the anxiety circuitry has the upper
edge in terms of potency and rapidity of
rise and fundamental
so long.
Okay,
so let me show you something.
Well,
it's also the case.
So racks,
they identify each other by smell,
and if you smell like you should smell,
then you're familiar.
You're not contaminated with the
unknown.
So your behavior is predictable,
which basically means that I know your
place in the dominance hierarchy.
I know what role you play with all the
other animals,
and I know how to behave in your
presence.
You're familiar.
You're Ken.
And I can tell that if I'm a rat bite of
the way that you spell,
okay,
so you take a rat that everyone loves
and you pull it out of its cage and you
wash it off and you throw it back in
with the rats would kill it because that
rat is now contaminated with the unknown
and we don't like to have the unknown
around because it upsets our
predictability and whatever.
Predictability gets upset that our
anxiety levels rise and all hell breaks
loose and literally all hell breaks
loose.
That's actually pam is a mythological
representations of the unknown.
These fats in part,
yeah,
from the mythological perspective of the
world has three constituent elements,
the unknown,
which is everywhere,
the known and the process by which one
has turned into the other,
which is basically exploration.
So the knower is the archetypical
archetipal pattern of expiration.
The thing that mediates between the
unknown and the known and from the
mythological perspective part of the
process creates the world.
See that's the,
that's absolutely fascinating too if you
think about it from him because he can
think about something like the fact of
say,
a our democratic system now,
our democratic system is deeply rooted
in religious presuppositions bidding,
which we forget now,
but it doesn't really matter.
They're still there.
They're implicit.
They're there.
Now,
one of the implicit presumptions is that
every individual in our society is
worthy of respect.
That's the core aspect of your natural,
right?
Fundamentally,
even if you're a criminal,
like even if you've broken rules that
you admit you broken in this society and
others that have the same preset
positions,
you,
you still have a whole sequence of
rights that cannot be violated because
in principle there's something about you
that's worthy of respect regardless of
your behavior.
The question is what is,
what is that?
Well,
I think even see this in simpler social
animals like wolves.
Yeah.
Oops.
Well,
they live in social groups.
They have dominance.
Hierarchies and wolves are always trying
to climb up the dominance hierarchy,
which is good for the wolf pack,
cause the strongest animal,
more or less,
the most competent animal.
It shouldn't be at the top,
but anyways,
if one will fight with another wolf and
they very seldom injure each other if
they're in the same group,
which is good because you don't want the
group diminished by constant intergroup
intergroup conflict.
Well,
the talk wolf,
the wolf who wins the conflict,
which is usually more of threat
posturing than actual physical
engagement,
although sometimes a real fight breaks
out if wolf that loses the dominance
dispute benefits submissive behaviors,
which basically means it rolls over and
shows its throat,
which means you can kill me now if you
want to talk,
we'll stops and you can say,
well,
the stronger wolf packs as if it's
constrained by knowledge that even the
weaker members of the group still can
conceivably contribute something of
value to the group.
Well,
that's what we're like to in our
organizations except we've got,
we've got that principal up almost to
the point where we understand that it's
the individual who in contact with the
unknown generates inflammation and that
inflammation constitutes the group and
the individual is valuable because they
are in fact assimilated to the
mythological perspective,
to the force that creates the world,
which is basically the forest that
renders the unknown,
predictable or that creates order out of
chaos and say the aspect of people
that's divine theoretically is the part
that stands on the border between the
unknown and the known and the most
information from unexplored territory in
two explored territory.
Expanding the dog to the dominion of the
group.
That's
okay.
Who's this?
I says Kelly,
the devour.
She's a negative mother,
so to speak,
from a mythological perspective and I
find very,
very interesting.
She's the best representation of this
sort of thing that I've ever seen.
If the myth that you think maths,
they last a long time,
sometimes tens of thousands of years and
they,
they often even last across cultures and
you think,
who are they?
How is it?
What could the story actually be telling
you that could be useful given that much
change?
Well,
the mythological world that stories are
concerned with is composed of three
things.
The unknown,
but it's always there.
It doesn't matter when you live or where
you live or who you are,
that's part of your experience.
It's always going to be part of your
experience.
It doesn't matter how much you know,
there's always things that you can
predict.
The more you know what the more
potential problems there are,
because knowledge in itself even breeds
new problems.
That's always there.
The fact of culture is always there.
I mean the cultures may change,
but the fact that there's culture and
that you're a product of culture and
that you have to add to it or at least
establish some relationship to it,
that it protects you and creates you and
that you contribute to it and that never
changes.
And the fact that you're the
intermediary between those two forces,
that never changes.
And that's what describes those three
things.
This is a representation of the unknown.
The unknown is also as well as being the
thing that gives rise to everything.
It's also the thing that destroys.
Everything gets on the things that we
cannot control it in the final analysis
lead to our demise.
It's our ignorance that causes our death
in a sense.
We just can't stop something.
He can't stop aging disease.
We can't stop starvation.
There's are all things that we haven't
got a grip on there.
All things that are still unknown,
unpredictable,
and sooner or later they get us.
Let's look at Kelly.
Well,
the first thing I'd like to say,
like I said,
the unknown automatically frightened to
us or other things that automatically
frightened us more or less.
There's some dispute about this and the
behavioral insurance.
There are things that you can learn to
become afraid of very easily.
Spiders,
snakes,
fire alarm skeletons,
disembodied bodies.
Those are all elements of horror movies.
It's pretty obvious that people are more
and less afraid of them.
It's not that difficult to figure out
why.
The only debate in them in the,
in the psychological literature is
whether those fears are actually nate or
whether you have to acquire them through
very brief exposure.
It doesn't matter as far as I'm
concerned.
The point is is that those things might
be regarded as
extraordinarily appropriate.
Representatives of the unknown.
What's myth trying to do?
It's trying to encapsulate behavioral
wisdom under what circumstances and what
world?
Well,
the answer to that is in the world
that's composed of the unknown,
the known and the mediating force say if
you have to adapt to the unknown,
which you have to do.
The thing to do logically say you'd have
an infinite amount of time at your
disposal is to come up with a
representation of what the unknown is a
strange thing to do because you don't
know what it is.
So the question is how the hell can you
represent it?
But the one thing you do know about it,
it's always the case is that it makes
you afraid and it makes you curious.
So if you want to make a representation
of it,
then you use those things that you do
know.
Something about that either make you
afraid or curious and let's look at this
figure figure to who,
whom at some point in history and not so
long ago,
human sacrifices pro actually offered
it.
We're on,
we're going to look a little bit at the
reasons for that.
This is Kelly.
She is the thing that everything goes
back to she's a representative of the
unknown.
Well,
let's look at her now.
She's something that produces religious
devotion in those who apprehend her
presence.
Seizure of meaning fundamentally,
which you could assimilate to and
religious experience.
She has eight legs like a spider.
She spins the web of faith.
That's the reason the web has made a
fire.
Her hair's on fire too by the way.
She sits in the middle of that way.
She has a head dress of skulls and
usually has a snake around her waist.
A snake's a symbol of transformation
because it sheds its skin,
so theoretically did something that's
reborn anyways.
Um,
she often has staring eyes protruding
teeth to something else that people are
pretty much in a predisposed to respond
to and she is so in her hands are tools
of creation and destruction and she's
simultaneously giving birth to this
gentleman and eating here.
That
symbol that,
and I would say,
well,
okay,
now you understand two things.
You understand that you have an innate
response for the unknown and the next
APP,
permanent constituent elements of
experience from the perspective of
emotion.
And if you look at figure like that,
then you can get some comprehension of
what it is that people are trying to
avoid contacting the attempt to maintain
things predictable.
Well,
I'm just going to close this,
I guess.
Um,
this is a hint about the second part of
the course.
So the first part of the car,
while it's going to,
there's one,
there's a lot more detail to the story
than I brand across today and there's
some complicating factors that make the
whole story much more interesting.
I mean,
this is interesting already.
I think this is the most,
this is,
has something to do with hope.
When let's say you're a natively
predisposed to respond to the
unpredictable with anxiety and perhaps
to eliminate it.
If you care,
you can understand why that is,
but you need to be able to predict your
circumstances.
You have to be able,
you kind of just give up your story or
your culture because that throws you
completely emptied chaos and that's
unpleasant because unpleasant does
anything you could imagine
what other people believe different
things and obviously when you come into
contact with him,
while there's a high likelihood of
depression and aggression of such
magnitude that there's a good
probability that you'll be destroyed and
some of the person that you're
aggressing against that just really
striking as you know,
all that greatest solution.
On the one hand you give up your ideas
for,
then you are subject to half active
dysregulation of the most intolerable.
Sorry.
On the other hand,
if you pursue your particular ideas in
the face of opposition,
then you might run into a circumstance
where aggression is inevitable and
that'd be the end of the year.
This is a bad sort of paradox.
Oh,
so what can be done about that?
Well that has,
I guess you could say,
to give you the answer in the tiniest
sort of the shelves and has something to
do with your attitude towards anomalous
information,
have the highest likelihood of not
falling into this sort of trap.
If when something unexpected happens to
you register and you explore it to see
why it was that you were wrong,
to accept the fact of the anomalous
information and to explore it.
This is a nice figure and I'll close
with a discussion with just a brief
discussion of this.
That's a bonus.
Sound Fun.
It's an eastern image.
Then I suppose you could assimilate to
some degree to Christ in the West.
It's an image of the hero and the hero
is the intermediary between the known
and the unknown.
Tierra.
Listen,
first one goes out where it's
frightening.
See this little dragon stories should
have mentioned that dragon dragons,
they live in the bottom of the mountain
and they sit on a treasure and if he
want to treasure you,
go out of your community is threatened
by the Dragon.
If you weren't the church you go to and
slayer overcome with drag.
Bringing back the treasure.
When you come back,
then your communities transform.
The last of the story about explorations
is the dragon isn't the thing to
simultaneously threatened in the
promising as well as archaic and ancient
and our full,
the hero is the person leaves in the
community to encounter that
arc in temple phenomena to overcome it,
to get the tragedy to bring it back to
the community,
which is therefore you rich.
That's the path of the hero.
This,
this is a very interesting image.
That finger see the attempt by the
author to make it recurring ready and
this is,
this is the sky by the way,
and this might be conceived of as a
tunnel,
but it's a tunnel into time and into
space.
This is the most,
this is the present and this is the
past.
Does it extends back as far as can
possibly be imagined.
This finger sits on me or I know,
I know it's kind of blurry and that's
unfortunate,
but let me see here.
See these fingers at the bottom.
These are figures that are very much
like Kelly,
same sort of thing.
This representation is this figure of
triumphing in a sense over this speaker,
this
swelling by fire as well,
and it's a symbol of transformation.
This is an attempt to portray the fact
that the pattern of behavior that is
characteristic of the hero is something
that constantly recurs through time.
That's an architect from the union
perspective,
just the fact of exploration and the
tendency for us,
that's an ending bill,
part of the human psyche biologically
predicate it.
It's part of the,
it's part of the apparatus that you
inherit,
so to speak.
It.
It's nothing to do with inherited
memories or anything,
anything,
man,
I'll just try.
It just has to do with the fact that
that's the sort of creature you are.
You're always,
you always serve as the intermediary
between unexplored territory,
unexplored territory.
That's true.
No matter where you live.
This is a finger then,
well that isn't drawing that attempts to
represent that idea pictorially.
It's very cold.
Most religious traditions,
perhaps with the exception
of course,
there's always exceptions are predicated
on the notion that identity identity
with this figure right in it with this
finger is necessarily up the core,
proper human adaptation.
And without that identification and
chaos will necessarily ring.
Okay,
sure.
Yeah.
So does everybody have a syllabus?
Okay.
Does everybody have the directions to
the coffee shop
for a
long time?
For a long time,
he was the only neuro psychologist that
I knew of in North America who's
actually interested in
some of the ideas that are
in
your name and your student Id.
You're welcome,
dawn
there.
Mark,
they're downstairs in my office.
I'm going to put the mode.
What's the course number?
Two four three five
no,
cause I have a sabbatical next year,
so it's,
it's not a good idea.
You should find someone who was around
as long as long as you're convinced that
you can.
Oh,
good.
Okay.
Do you have any
oh,
12 bucks or something?
Some very expensive.
Okay,
thanks.
Yup.
Mechanisms
you might try.
Rich
might be relevant.